[Musique]
1723 en 1685 Louis XIV qui met fin à la
tolérance religieuse envers le
protestantisme en France signe aussi
unit royale préparé par Colbert
instaurant un Code noir en Martinique et
en
Guadeloupe il s'agit de réglementer en
60 articles la vie des esclaves et le
avec les maîtres les esclaves sont
considérés comme des biens meubles que
l'on peut acheter et vendre en même
temps ils peuvent se marier
religieusement il n'est plus possible de
séparer enfants et parents ils ont droit
au repos le dimanche et comme ils sont
baptisés ils ont droit à une sépulture
le maître est tenu d'habiller
correctement ses esclaves et de les
nourrir les actes de désobéissance sont
d'une sévérité absolue en particulier à
l'égard du maronnage il est prévu aussi
qu'un esclave affranchi ait les mêmes
droits qu'une personne n'est libre dans
les fait les colons continueront à
traiter les esclave comme ils
l'entendent ce code fut progressivement
étendu et adapté pour Saint-Domingue en
1684 pour la Guyane en 1704 pour Bourbon
et l'île-de-fance en
1723 sous le nom de lettre patente puis
en Louisiane en
1724 le texte initial fut modifié à
trois reprises avant de disparaître
en
1848 1723 les lettres patentes du roi
dites Code
[Musique]
noir